alrighty everybody it is time for drew's
news the only news with an ulcer free
guarantee
and with me at the desk is my human tum
tum tum tums rossi ross matthias
[Applause]
yeah you are human medicine thank you i
love you so much i love you drew how's
your day going so far so good how about
you
i got really weird bad news and then
really good news and i was like that's
so life oh god right like balance
yeah you know that's how my morning's
been yeah good so we're good yeah we're
great all right great bring it on well
um speaking of ah
harry styles is set to hit the coachella
stage again this next weekend because he
already nailed it this past weekend
marie claire reports that harry brought
out a surprise guest pop icon shania
twain and they both pressed that
in head to toe sequins they said they
sang man i feel like a woman which is a
great title because it includes
everybody yeah and harry revealed that
he listened to so much shania with his
mom
in the car growing up he says that
shania taught him how to sing
gave him amazing memories with his mom
and also taught him men are trash
harry's album coming out called harry's
house
is uh about to drop but his first single
has already broken records as it got 16
million streams in its first 24 hours on
spotify yeah yeah
i think i think i was responsible for
like a million of those
i love harry styles he's so talented and
then he brings out shania twain well
that do impressive me much thank you so
much
i love i love shania twain and you know
coachella have you guys ever been to
coachella
me either oh wait
yeah it sounds like so much i live in
palm springs when i'm not hearing that's
right you're so adjacent totally and you
can hear the
thump of it going on and meanwhile
i'm like pouring a pinot grigio on ice
by the pool because it is too
much for me but harry styles might just
bring me out i i love that i said harry
styles might bring me out well honey i'm
already out but you know what i mean you
are out you know
what i mean
if anyone could do it again
[Music]
you